il faudra bientôt être majeur et vacciné
pour entrer dans les succursales de la
société des alcools et de la société
québécoise du cannabis dans douze jours
le passeport vaccinale il sera exigé
mais les non-vaccinés pourront toujours
commander en ligne un coup de semonce
qui aurait joué plusieurs oui monsieur
je prends ma responsabilité comme
citoyen je crois que les gens qui ne
font pas ça doivent subir risque les
conséquences si ça va frustrer personne
mais oui je serais d'accord je trouve ça
bien dans le
jeu parce qu'elle m'a donné les nouveax
n'est saison qui me trouble québec se
défend de les punir même si le ministre
du buisson ligne que les non vaccinés
représente plus de la moitié des
patients atteints de l'aco vide
hospitalisé aux soins intensifs
je comprends cause pourraient être
tentés de dire que ce serait plaisant de
les emmerder je pensais monsieur m'a
conquis vous référer mais moi je pense
que le premier objectif c'est de limiter
les contacts le deuxième objectif c'est
de les protéger contre humain
si le gouvernement legault ne compte pas
imposer le passeport vaccinale pour
accéder aux épiceries et aux pharmacies
il pourrait l'étendre à l'ensemble du
commerce non essentiels ce sera
notamment le cas pour les services de
soins personnels comme le salon coiffure
ça va être difficile parce que j'ai des
clients qui n'ont pas fait le vaccin ni
le premier ni nude et si des clientes
est vraiment fidèle donc comme si je
vais les perdre si le bus et de punir
les non-vaccinés ya peut-être d'autres
moyens envisageables le conseil
québécois du commerce au détail espère
que québec n'étendra pas de passeport
vaccinale à tous les commerces non
essentiels un fardeau supplémentaire en
pleine pénurie de main d'oeuvre ajoutez
un employé à la porte c'est ça pose des
questions logistiques assez intense donc
on pose réellement la question si nos
deux tiers sont capable de l'appliquer
le conseil du patronat appuyé quant à
lui la démarche du gouvernement irait
encore plus loin le gouvernement devrait
exiger hadopi catoire la vaccination et
ainsi protéger la chambre de l'acteur ap
québec confirme qu'une troisième dose
sera nécessaire pour avoir un passeport
vaccinale valide mais on est sera le
temps la population de la recevoir si
olivier vachon réseau canada montréal